tell me about the ship it's a
research expedition ship and i have a
team of scientists who help me do that
or or do that real they take the lead
and so we put that together and then i
went to um jim cameron because we've
known each other because we're he's
passionate about ocean exploration and
he said well why don't you take that
chip and and do it uh with the best
media possible so that you can show it
to everybody like jacques doe you know
like he's laid it out with the
the lighting and so on so it's a little
bit like a starship enterprise on the
ocean with these people doing real
research we can
take a remote operated vehicles goes
down six thousand meters we have manned
submersibles that go down a thousand
meters we have a 3d 360 degree camera we
can go to any spot in the ocean okay
when we can bring you there there are
dna type of samplings there's
discovering of species there's amazing
technology that can bring you anywhere
and also vividly
show it to you